division is really kind of the
smokescreen for the corruption in
Washington it is the misdirection in the
magic trick that gets us looking at
wedge issues and things that divide us
and pit people against each other
reasontv I'm Sharif matar we're sitting
here with christopher k director of the
film of x for a film about political
dysfunction in america today this is his
directorial debut along with producer
Chad mornin it's not about right versus
left it's not for or against any one
politician or party it seeks to strike a
different chord not one of division but
of commonality and respect because we
have far more in common than we've been
led to believe describe why you decided
to make the film the original idea was
chance actually a good friend of his was
one of Reagan's speech writers and
called him up and asked him to give me a
hand on the primary trail and so Chad
got to see all the behind-the-scenes
debate prep finances and really got to
see kind of the inside scoop on money
and just the way our kind of primary
system works and so he got done with
that and no not because of nude or
anything but was pretty frustrated and
disillusioned a bit you know and so he
called me up you know and just said hey
man this is crazy what do you think's
going on here you know like why don't
let's just take a trip across on route
66 and grab a couple cameras and you
know see what other people think so
that's how it started we were kind of
astonished to find what we did we
expected extremely you know kind of
polarized views into the two traditional
camps of left and right you know and
pretty much across the board whether it
was young old black white gay straight
occupier Tea Party a lot of people were
pretty disillusioned as well and pretty
sober about a lot of the areas of
dysfunction in the country so then we
decided you know we should
take this to Washington you know I mean
kind of our discovery of the views of
the American people and see what the
people on the inside think the number of
goodies on the table so great you're
going to get lobbies where's my temple
you hear you nobody comes to this town
to get rich this is the business of
power we set out all along deciding that
we weren't going to you know forgive me
Michael but we weren't going to Michael
Moore anyone you know that we are going
to be respectful and ask people from
across the political spectrum what they
believed why did you think it was so
important to talk to average people and
not just political insiders well first
of all we just wanted to confirm whether
we were crazy or not you know I me and I
was feeling a bit despondent for
different reasons than Chad but you know
we were simply wondering like are we
alone like are we you know in our little
town in Ohio here you know a bit myopic
or what's going on you know and so we
wanted to talk to our fellow citizens
but I think clearly you know there's
been a widening gap between the reality
of Washington or in the perception of
Washington and the perceptions and the
reality of everyday people and
mainstream America which of the
interviews kind of stood out and kind of
vocalized some of the ideas that this
film was about best I mean certainly the
most interesting and revealing interview
was with Jack Abramoff and I think going
back to what sets this documentary apart
from maybe others you really get to see
kind of you know behind the curtain what
happens day one freshman orientation you
know when congressmen and senators are
introduced to lobbyists and how that
system of money and influence really
really works most people if you say hey
you know money drives politics or
whatever like yeah no kidding you know I
mean but getting to hear firsthand
stories of exactly how money grips
people and turns otherwise well-meaning
largely principled people when they come
to Washington how they quickly are
turned it's in the film we talk about
the tax law a little bit you know since
nineteen thirteen the tax code was 400
pages it is now we have averaged two
pages of tax code per day weekends also
and all of their vacations two pages of
tax law per day for the last 100 years
that is a tremendous power that is
something that is for sale and it is
clearly the way in which that Washington
largely both benefits and punishes your
friends and your foes most of the
lobbying in Washington is centered
around tax loopholes tax benefits as
well as regulations Dennis Kucinich and
Ron Paul that largely agree on things
like the federal reserve war and debt
and have been working their entire
careers to try and change some of those
things you know pretty common-sense
things you know when you hear that how
the Federal Reserve has never been
audited as a private bank that has
complete control over a monetary system
most rational people think that's pretty
astounding you know but yet somehow even
though it's introduced every year by dr.
pol you know it never passes you know I
mean and so this they would describe the
system as almost having this kind of
character and life of its own that they
were almost outside of nobody I exactly
said I can't change anything around Paul
actually did in an off comment but the
way that they spoke about it in or mean
is this kind of removed thing that they
almost weren't a part of this film
almost assumes that you know the average
citizen should be politically active do
you think that that's fair and is that
accurate the whole thing is based on
that we all have a stake in it we all
have some skin in the game you know this
Republic won't last very long if we
continue with more
more and more and more money and power
going into fewer and fewer hands that's
a very very dangerous trajectory and one
that we can't sustain and it's also
resonant in the idea that most people
seem to say with marginal differences
differences mostly social there's little
difference between the are two current
parties you know on the major issues of
war debt poverty education now even
health care they're largely the same
they behave the same way reasons Nick
Gillespie and Matt Welch have authored a
book Declaration of Independence and
it's about kind of a sort of this third
way do you find this sort of consensus
on this almost third way in the general
public or was it not that simple the
amount of people that said you know I
just love Ron Paul was remarkable
because he represented a different way
he represented things that people both
on the left and the right resonated well
with and especially on the major issues
you know so yeah I I think that's
something that people long for a lot I
mean in Ohio we just had the state
legislature all but outlawed third
parties it's appalling to everyone even
if you're you know a hardcore party line
democrat or republican the idea that you
would you know you would exclude someone
that's kind of tragic you know how are
you know alternative views or third
parties kind of shut out of the system
how does that how does that play out in
actual on the ground the gerrymandering
in the film we have some maps of the
gerrymandering maps that go on and this
is the system by which the state
legislatures draw the boundaries of the
districts they look like ink blots or
workshop well you know tests they're
just absolutely crazy it's just nearly
it is impossible for a third party to
overcome currently
in the final analysis Washington thrives
on two things money because you have to
have it to run and it is the means by
which everything gets done but division
is really kind of the smokescreen for
the corruption in Washington and is the
misdirection in the magic trick that
gets us looking at wedge issues and
things that divide us and pit people
against each other change fundamental
change I think young voters in this
country have to vote for me if they're
really thinking about what's in the best
interest of the country and what's in
their personal best interest fight with
me
the whole time